[GOOGLE LOGO MUSIC]
MANDY CHAN: So
welcome to our talk,
How to Build Actions for Smart
Displays and More Devices.
I'm Mandy Chan.
I'm a developer advocate for
the Actions on Google Team.
I'm very passionate about
improving the developer
experience.
And that mean I care about
you and your experience
on our platform.
During our talk-- oh, sorry.
DARLA SHARP: That's OK.
MANDY CHAN: During our talk, if
you find something interesting,
and you want to
share it, please use
the hashtag #AoGDev on Twitter.
DARLA SHARP: And I'm Darla.
I'm a conversation designer
on the Google Assistant.
I work on how the
Assistant looks and sounds
across all our devices, with
the hope that it's consistent,
useful, and, dare I say, fun
to use from time to time.
Today, we're going
to talk about how
we combined our powers as
a designer and a developer
to create a custom
Action on Google,
and share with you what
we learned along the way.
MANDY CHAN: So there
are many different ways
you can build for
the Google Assistant.
If you're an Android
app developer,
you can build what
we call app Actions.
If you are a content owner, you
can build how-to actions or FAQ
actions quickly by
using our templates.
In this talk, we
will be focusing
on building a custom action,
in particular, a game action.
You will leave this
talk with a strategy
on how to build a multi-model
experience that scales
across different devices.
So you can see on the screen,
we have different tools
that we used to build this game.
First one is Dialogflow.
It make it very straightforward
to build a custom actions.
It turn unstructured
natural language input
into a structure representation
that my endpoint can consume.
Under the hood,
Dialogflow is built
on the Google's machine
learning and natural language
understanding.
Firebase is a mobile
and web development
platform that allows you to
scale your application quickly.
And, for my game, I've
used Cloud Function, Cloud
Firestore, as well
as Firebase Storage
for my backend integration.
DARLA SHARP: Mandy is
covering the important tools
you need in order to
build a custom Action.
I'll be talking about how we
applied solid Conversation
Design principles to ensure
it's a good experience.
MANDY CHAN: Lastly,
Actions on Google
is our developer platform that
allows you developers to extend
the functionality for
the Google Assistant
and build Actions to make your
user's life more productive,
get things done quickly.
So, for I/O this year,
I've been viewing
this game called Virtual Pet.
My initial motivation was to
understand from the developer
perspective what it's like to
build a game on our platform.
Before we dive into
the presentation,
I want to give you a taste
of how the game start.
And please pay attention to the
animation in the background.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[DOOR CREAKS]
[BELL RINGS]
DARLA SHARP: Oh, look at
this super cute pet store.
- Welcome to Super
Petz adoption event.
I'm so glad you're here.
Are you interested in
adopting a pet today?
DARLA SHARP: Not it.
MANDY CHAN: Yes, OK.
- That's great.
I'll be helping you today.
It's nice to meet you.
First things first,
what's your name
that you'd like to put
on the adoption form?
MANDY CHAN: Well, Mandy.
[WRITING]
- Nice to meet you, Mandy.
Taking on a pet is a
big responsibility.
So, if you don't mind, I'd like
to ask you a question or two.
Now, a pet will need to be
fed and exercised every day.
Are you going to be able to feed
and exercise your pet daily?
MANDY CHAN: I think so.
So, yes.
[WRITING]
- That's great.
You seem qualified to
continue with the adoption.
I'm somewhat of
a matchmaker when
it comes to matching pets
with the right owner.
And I think I have the
perfect pet for you.
They're cute, furry, and
ready to be your best friend.
Are you ready?
[JOYFUL SQUEAL]
MANDY CHAN: Yes, I
am totally ready.
- The grand reveal--
it's a hamster, just for you.
[END PLAYBACK]
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
MANDY CHAN: So everyone
meet Larry, my hamster, who
inspired me to build this game.
Larry is a little
bit shy right now.
Hey, Larry.
[CHUCKLES]
So this is a historic
moment, the first hamster
who attends I/O and
co-presenting at Google I/O
Stage.
So everyone please
give Larry a paw.
[APPLAUSE]
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Now, this hamster
needs a name.
What do you think
the name should be?
[END PLAYBACK]
DARLA SHARP: Mandy, does this
hamster have credentials?
MANDY CHAN: Well,
just like everybody
else who is attending Google
I/O, we all have a badge.
Larry is no exception.
Telo, why don't we show
everyone Larry's I/O badge?
Well, he actually-- that
one is too big for him.
We actually make a legit
tiny one for Larry.
The I/O team is
really like excited
that we have first
hamster presenting at I/O.
DARLA SHARP: OK, so I see his
name there is Larry Walnuts--
MANDY CHAN: Right.
DARLA SHARP:
--according to his--
MANDY CHAN: Larry
Walnuts is his full name.
DARLA SHARP: --his
identification.
OK.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- That's such a good name.
Before you take your
pet home, there's
a few things to mention.
Be sure to check on
your pet every day.
Otherwise, they may
get sick or hungry.
[STAMP]
Ready to bring Larry home?
[END PLAYBACK]
DARLA SHARP: Are we ready
to bring Larry home?
MANDY CHAN: Yes.
So Larry's full-time
job is taking a nap
during the daytime.
So, today, he make
extra effort to come
to I/O. At nighttime,
he like to play.
So why don't we let Larry get
back to work and take a nap?
Thank you, Telo, for
bringing Larry to the stage.
[APPLAUSE]
DARLA SHARP: OK, so let's look
at what Larry's home really
looks like--
MANDY CHAN: Right.
DARLA SHARP: --in the game.
MANDY CHAN: How's Larry
home look like in the game?
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[FOOTSTEPS]
- This looks like a very
cozy home for Larry.
As a caring owner, you'll
be rewarded with badges.
Collect the badges to unlock
new food and toys for your pet.
Now, do you want to
feed or play with Larry?
[END PLAYBACK]
DARLA SHARP: So, as an
extra surprise today,
everybody look
under your chairs.
You get a hamster.
Everybody gets a Google hamster.
Just kidding.
That's a terrifying proposal.
Nobody's getting
a hamster today.
OK, let's get back to work.
There are five
important concepts
that we're going to
talk about today.
We're going to talk about
each of these in more detail.
But before we do, let's touch
on each of them briefly,
so everybody knows
what to expect.
So the first one is the voice
experience is the foundation.
When it comes to
Actions on Google,
it's not the device
or the screen
that drives the experience.
It's the voice.
So when it comes to
Actions on Google,
the voice experience is king.
MANDY CHAN: Second lesson
that we want you to take away
is use dialogue
to guide the user.
And what that really
mean is set expectation
and drive your
conversation forward
by using questions
instead of statements.
DARLA SHARP: We'll
talk about how
to use Rich Responses to
augment your voice experience
if your Action uses a screen.
Rich Responses can visually
augment your Action, drive
discoverability, and offload
information from your TTS
prompts.
MANDY CHAN: We will discuss
how to use Interactive Canvas,
a new feature that we just
announced yesterday at I/O, how
to really use Interactive
Canvas to create
a immersive, dynamic gaming
experience for the user.
DARLA SHARP: And finally,
you're not building
unique experiences per device.
You're building one cohesive
experience that scales.
First, let's quickly talk
about the Assistant Devices.
When it comes to building an
experience for the Assistant,
there are many ways and
surfaces to reach users.
What we're going to
do today is help you,
the developers, reach users
through the 1 billion devices
enabled with the
Google Assistant.
MANDY CHAN: So by building
actions on our platform,
we help you reach
billions of users.
And all of these devices
support different capabilities.
Currently, we support five
different capabilities.
The first two are
pretty straightforward.
Does your device
support screen output?
And does your device
support audio output?
Word process is pretty
straightforward, too.
Does your device can
show a web browser?
For example, Chromebook
and mobile phone.
Media Response allows you
to play long audio files.
Lastly, Custom Stage--
this is a new one that
related to Interactive Canvas.
If your device can support
Interactive Canvas,
right now Interactive Canvas
are support on smart displays
and Android forms.
One thing in this slide I want
to point out is as a developer,
you don't really know
the type of devices
that your user trigger
your actions on.
But you do know the
capabilities of that device.
Remember, that's all you can
check, which is capabilities.
DARLA SHARP: So now
that we've covered
some of the overall capabilities
of the device spectrum
and how to account for them in
the code, let's talk about how
we manage to build one action
that scales to the top three
popular devices--
smart speakers, mobile,
and smart displays.
These three devices cover
all the surface capabilities
that Mandy just mentioned.
MANDY CHAN: So let's
go through the game
that we just demoed
earlier, the Virtual Pet.
In this game, you will
first adopt a hamster.
And just like any real pet
you have owned in real life,
you need to make sure they're
happy by getting them lots
of healthy food and exercise.
As you can see, Larry
loves to go shopping.
I will take you through
the actual process
that we experienced when
we were building the game,
showing you the
mistakes that we made,
so you can learn from them.
Let's talk about how the
game works and its flow.
One of the motivations
behind me building this game
is to maximize the capabilities
of different devices.
To leverage the concept found
in traditional game plays,
such as rewards, levels,
and managing states,
let me walk through
this diagram quickly.
First, when you enter the game,
you have to adopt the hamster.
And then in the
orange area, this
is everything you can do
after you adopt a pet.
You can ask for
the pet's status.
You can ask for what kind
of badges have you earned.
During a game play,
you will be rewarded
with different badges
based on the activities
that you do with your pets.
Once you collect
enough badges, you
will progress to the next level.
And the next level allows you
to unlock new toys for your pet.
DARLA SHARP: So, when we
started working together,
one of the first
questions we asked
was, what device did we
think we should focus on?
For us, it was
the Smart Display.
We thought that beautiful
screen could really
help bring Larry to life.
So we started with
that and decided
we'd focus on the
other devices later.
So let's talk
about what the game
was like before our
collaboration, what
it was like after, and
the lessons we learned.
MANDY CHAN: So when I
first built the game,
I was very eager to
jump into the game play,
because that's where
the magic happens--
the images, the sound effects,
and all the creative aspect
that go into the game.
For example, for the greeting
experience of the game,
I just jumped into what we call
the default welcoming tent.
I didn't really think about
the narrative, the beginning
of the experience.
Let's listen.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Welcome to Virtual Pet Game.
We have a lovely hamster
waiting for a home.
Before we get started,
please tell me your name.
[END PLAYBACK]
MANDY CHAN: As you just heard,
the beginning experience
was not very exciting.
And it was really awkward that
you just jumped into and asked
the user, what's your name?
We need to give them the
reasons before we ask
for any information like that.
And all of this changed when
Darla asked me a few questions
I didn't think before.
DARLA SHARP: When Mandy
first showed me this game,
one of the first questions
I had before I even
wanted to tell the name was,
who's talking right now?
Who is the "we" in we have
a lovely hamster waiting
for a home?
I hadn't even started
playing the game yet,
and I was a little bit confused.
This simple question,
who is talking,
actually has pretty
profound implications
for the work we needed to do.
The primary one is that
we needed to focus first
on the voice experience.
Thanks so much to our
colleague, Darren Hilton,
who did this amazing
artwork for this game,
the artwork was solid.
The voice experience
needed a little work.
So we backed up the train.
Rather than immediately
introducing the pet
and asking for the
user's name, we
created an entirely new
experience, a pet adoption
experience.
We start in a relatable
way, in getting
users engaged by asking them if
they're ready to adopt a pet.
Let's listen.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Welcome to Super
Petz adoption event.
I'm so glad you're here.
Are you interested in
adopting a pet today?
[END PLAYBACK]
DARLA SHARP: We'll talk
more about the rest
of the pet adoption experience
here in a little bit.
But the takeaway here is with
a little bit of creativity,
and thinking about what
might be a natural way
to talk to your users,
you can use dialogue
to create a fun and
engaging experience.
So this is something
we learned together.
When we first asked
ourselves, what device
should we build for,
that was a bit of a trap.
It's common trap to try and
build for the smart display
because it's got that screen.
You can do so much
with that screen.
But it's not the screen
that drives the experience.
It's the voice.
So one of the first and
most impactful lessons--
focus on the voice.
But if the voice experience
is the foundation,
how do you do it well,
especially if you've never
done it before?
We're going to walk through
how conversation design applied
to our game and then give you
lots of resources at the end
to learn more.
MANDY CHAN: You will see this
experience enrichment pyramid
throughout our talk.
And overall, the idea is
voice first is the foundation
that we built on.
Let's take a look
at what that mean.
We developers, we tend to build
applications that are linear.
We do things in sequence.
Before we created the
pet store experience,
the user was rushed
into feeding the pet.
Let's take a listen.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Congratulations.
You adopted Larry.
Larry is a little hungry.
Do you want to feed Larry
some broccoli, a carrot,
or sunflower seeds?
[END PLAYBACK]
MANDY CHAN: So this
approach is actually not
good for voice first experience.
We don't do things
in linear when you
develop a voice applications.
DARLA SHARP: So my question
was, when Mandy showed me this,
was, is feeding the
pet all you can do?
By presenting this
one option, it sort of
implied that that was it.
So this, again, fairly simple
question of what can you do
has pretty profound
implications.
For us, it meant that we
needed to solve what we often
call the discovery problem.
This is a common problem
in voice interactions.
If users can't see the
options, how are they
going to know what they can do?
For us, there was many
unresolved aspects
that Mandy had
built into the game
that we needed to figure
out how to share with users.
So one thing you need
to ask yourself is,
how do you do this
in the real world?
If I want to tell you all
the things you need to know,
I don't just tell you all
of the things right away.
I tell you a little
bit at a time
in a way that makes
sense using something
we call progressive disclosure.
So we built in this
pet store experience
to the beginning of
the game, so that we
could use progressive
disclosure to have
an engaging conversation
with the user.
So after the user has
entered the pet store,
we built in a
pre-adoption interview
to teach the user the game.
Think about what happens
when you adopt a pet.
They want to make sure
you're going to be
able to take care of it, right?
Let's take a listen.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Nice to meet you.
Taking on a pet is a
big responsibility.
So if you don't mind, I'd like
to ask you a question or two.
Now, a pet will need to be
fed and exercised every day.
Are you going to be able to feed
and exercise your pet daily?
[END PLAYBACK]
DARLA SHARP: So with
this one prompt,
we were able to do two
really important things.
One, we taught
the user that this
is not a one-time game that you
play once and don't come back.
We wanted you to come back
every day, take care of your pet
like you would a real pet.
So this is one way we
hope to drive engagement.
Another thing we
mentioned here is
that you need to feed
and exercise your pet.
So now we use dialogue
to teach the user
the expectations of the game.
So another big
lesson here, when you
have the multimodal experience
and you focus on the voice,
dialogue is how the
action gets moved forward.
Have fun, use progressive
disclosure to guide the user.
One important thing
to keep in mind
when using dialogue to drive
the experience forward is you
want to always make sure
it's really clear when
it's the user's turn to talk.
Use questions, the more focused
the question, the better.
There's a few things to
keep in mind when creating
a complete voice experience.
Once you start
building dialogues,
keep in mind for every yes
path, there's a no path.
So for the question we had, are
you ready to adopt a pet today?
MANDY CHAN: Nope.
DARLA SHARP: What's
your action going to do?
What if the user says
something outside
of the very one specific thing
you intend for them to say?
So if I say, are you ready
to adopt a pet today?
MANDY CHAN: Potato.
DARLA SHARP: What's
your action going to do?
It's important that you have
a way to get your users back
on track.
So by nature, your
voice experience
needs to have several
branches here.
This way, you've counted
not only for the one
thing you expect users to
say, but all the things
they reasonably can say.
If your action doesn't
have many branching paths,
you've probably only built for
one instead of all of them.
So let's look at a
couple of ways we added
branching into Mandy's game.
So one, when a user
comes back to this game,
depending on how long it had
been since they had played,
they'd be greeted with
a different greeting.
Depending on whether they were
a good owner, an iffy owner,
or a bad owner, they'd
hear a different prompt.
Even within these modules
of good owner, iffy owner,
and bad owner, we have
several variants within that.
This is important,
especially with games
like this that you expect
users to come back many times.
You want to make
sure that they're
greeted in a dynamic way
and not always getting
the same experience.
Another way that we added in
some branching to Mandy's game
was now that users know how to
feed and exercise their pet,
what happens if they don't stop?
They could potentially
get stuck in what
we call an infinite loop.
This is harder to do
in visual interfaces
but is a common trap
in voice interactions
if you're not careful.
So what we did was
build in a mechanism
to track how many
times that day they
had interacted with the action
by feeding or exercising
their pet.
If they reached
the threshold, now,
instead of continuing
forever, they'd
get a notification
that was saying, hey,
your pet is really
tired or full.
Come back tomorrow to
interact with your pet.
MANDY CHAN: So we
talk about this,
the importance of building
a voice first experience.
Darla just mentioned branching
out your dialogue is one way.
There are two other
simple, yet powerful ways
to create that solid
voice first experience.
First one is SSML, which
allows you to create
layers for your actions.
You can create pauses.
You can change the volume
and pitch of the voice.
You can even add ambient
sound in the background
when the spoken
prompt is playing.
Second one is for
developers who don't
have a professional audio team.
We at Google provide
you the Sound Library
you can use to create
that immersive experience.
What I like about the
Sound Library is it's
organized by categories.
You can find animal sounds,
cartoons, science fiction.
It's even searchable.
So another thing is
it's completely free.
So take advantage
of them, and use it
in your game or any
categories of Actions.
In the demo, I showed
earlier that as a user walk
into the pet store, you
can hear the bells ringing
above the door that
alerts the pet store owner
someone has entered the store.
This all can help you to create
that narrative, really great
beginning gaming experience.
Now, we are going to touch
on the visual components that
apply to all the devices with a
screen by using Rich Responses.
Now, we're going up a
level in the pyramid.
At this tier, we are trying to
engage with the user with more
of their senses.
With smart displays,
in addition to a voice,
you can now engage with
the user by showing images
on the screen.
And they can select
the item by touch.
This is where the multimodal
experience begins.
We do this by using
Rich Responses
such as basic cards, carousels,
and suggestion chips.
By following this pyramid
strategy I just mentioned,
if the user plays the
game on a speaker,
you will hear the sound
of a hamster munching
in the background.
DARLA SHARP: Let's listen.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- [MUNCHING]
[END PLAYBACK]
MANDY CHAN: So you
can find all kind
of different, interesting
sound from our Sound Library
for your Actions.
So the initial
version of the game,
I really wanted to make
use of the features that
are available for the
developer at that time.
And that was before
Interactive Canvas.
So I make use of the Rich
Responses, majority of them
are basic cards, to fully
leverage a beautiful artwork
created by my coworker, Darren.
As you can see, the
image itself can
convey a lot of information.
It doesn't just show the
activity of the pet is doing,
but also the emotion of the pet.
DARLA SHARP: One of the
benefits of your action
having a screen is now
you're able to display
multiple options
at the same time.
This can be a little bit tricky
in the voice-only experience,
because users have to keep
that information in their head.
But now, with the screen, you
can present multiple options
and obviously get
the benefit of being
able to augment those options
with a visual representation.
There's a couple
things to keep in mind
here when trying
to balance the two
modalities of voice and screen.
If you've got a small
number of options,
like three, maybe
four, you probably
don't need to change
your prompt from
your voice-only experience.
It's perfectly fine to say, I
have a few options, A, B, or C.
Which one do you want?
But if you have more
options, four or more,
then it's probably a
good idea to offload
some of that information
from your prompts
to show the user the screen.
So then you can just say,
here's a few options.
Which one do you want?
MANDY CHAN: So for
this game specifically,
there are two opportunities that
we can leverage the carousel.
What should I feed my pet?
Or what can I do with my pet?
In this example is what
can I feed the pet?
With the carousel,
the user can either
select a item by saying
that I want a broccoli
or by touching the screen.
Keep in mind that you should
have a minimum of 2 items
or maximum 10
items for carousel.
Now, let's talk about how to
create a carousel in code.
We first create a new
instance of carousel,
parsing in multiple options, in
this case, broccoli and carrot.
And then for each item,
we have a key broccoli.
When the user select the
item, the value broccoli
will be sent back to the server.
And each item, we have a
title, description, and next
is the image.
And they have also a alt
attribute for accessibility.
Now, you have learned about how
to create a carousel in code,
it is very important to optimize
your TTS, Test To Speech,
for voice and screen.
What that really means is
pretty much like me giving
a presentation, do you
want me to read the word
from the screen word for word?
You don't.
So you don't want your
action to behave the same.
The solution for this
is pretty simple.
Make sure your spoken
prompt and the display
tests are different.
Here's how I do it in code.
So I first importing two
prompt, one's rich prompt,
and the other one
is static prompt.
And that's just my
personal preference
that I like to
separate those files.
When I say rich prompt,
what I really mean
is the display test that
you show on the screen.
Next.
So here, the
highlighted line is just
sending out the spoken prompt,
which the device will say.
And, as a part of building
the voice first experience,
I want you to be aware of before
you send any visual component,
like basic cards, carousel,
make sure you send the static--
the simple response first.
If you don't do this,
you might get an error.
Finally, if we do have a
device that supports screen,
we can show the image
of the basic card
with the rich prompt.
DARLA SHARP: Another
useful Rich Response to use
is suggestion chips, which is
a nice way to continue or pivot
the conversation.
A few things to keep in mind
when using suggestion chips--
the first one is less is more.
The more chips you put on the
bottom of the page, the more
implicit work you're
asking the user
to do to figure out which
one they need or want.
Use less.
Do the work for the user.
And only surface a few
highly relevant chips.
The second thing
to keep in mind is
that these are meant to augment
your feature by highlighting
secondary features.
With smart displays,
you can't ever
really be sure that the
user is standing right
in front of the device.
So if you expect them to use
this as their primary modality,
they may not even
be looking at it.
So use this as a way to
surface secondary features
for your action.
MANDY CHAN: So as Darla
mentioned, suggestion chips
can help you pivot
the conversation.
In this game, there are
two suggestion chips.
First one is how to get badges
so that the user know that are
they progressing in the game.
The second one is
how is the pet doing.
This is a great way to do
the progressive disclosure.
Let's see how we
do that in code.
It's pretty straightforward.
Again, you're creating a
new instance of suggestions.
You can parse in a single
string or an array of strings.
Depending on what
you are parsing in,
we can create a
single suggestion chip
or multiple suggestion chips.
So, so far, we
have covered a lot
of useful Rich Responses,
basic cards, carousel,
and suggestion chips.
We have several more, though,
that can help you and reach
your multimodal experience.
First is list.
List is pretty
much like carousel,
except you can show more items.
And then media
response really allows
you to play long audio file
and let the user navigate
an audio file.
Table, on the other
hand, can allow
you to display information
in row or column format.
We have more resources at
the end of the presentation
to show you how to
use each of them.
The lesson to be learned
here are two things.
Make sure you engage with
your user on a visual level.
The second one is, provide a
natural progressive discovery
without being so explicit
by using Rich Responses.
So we have talked about this
pyramid throughout our talk.
I just want to
have a quick recap.
SSML and Sound Library allows
you to express the creativity
through sound.
And that allows you to build a
solid voice first experience.
Rich Responses let
you present images,
but they are slightly limited.
That means that you
cannot customize them.
At the top of the pyramid is
where we have the Interactive
Canvas, that can
allows you to create
the deepest level of experience
by using Interactive Canvas.
This is a new feature
we announced yesterday.
And it empowers you to create a
fluid and customized experience
with the technology you are
already familiar with, HTML,
CSS, and JavaScript.
I like to say, this is
where the creativity
erupts, like a
volcano, because Canvas
allows you to be very
expressive, which
is ideal for a game.
Right now, this is only
available for a game.
On the other hand,
Rich Responses,
you can use them for any
categories of Actions.
You can see what's
on the screen.
DARLA SHARP: Ooh.
MANDY CHAN: This can
all be done with--
DARLA SHARP: Ah.
MANDY CHAN: --HTML,
CSS, and JavaScript.
With Interactive
Canvas, you can easily
create dynamic animations.
Canvas let the user touch on
any element on the screen,
and they can react.
None of this was
possible before Canvas.
DARLA SHARP: So we
needed to figure out,
how are we going to use
Canvas for our game?
When the users come back
to the game, Larry--
or your hamster, however
you've named them--
can be in any number of states.
They can be happy.
They could be hungry,
holding his little belly,
thinking you're never
going to feed him.
It could even be sleeping.
So what we wanted
to be sure to do
was make it clear
for the user how
what they're doing for their
pet is affecting the pet based
on all of the complexity that
Mandy had built into the game.
So now let's take a look
about how we replaced
Rich Responses with Canvas.
MANDY CHAN: Like I said
earlier, I built this game
when Canvas was available.
So I used a lot of,
like, Rich Responses,
such as basic cards and
carousel, in my game.
In this example, when the
user choose let the pet run
in a hamster ball, my intent
with the spoken prompt
is to show that Larry is happy.
Larry still have energy to play.
But what I didn't think
about is, how does that
affect the end-user game play?
What if the user keep
playing and feeding the pet?
My game, the initial
version, would just
keep displaying the same images.
DARLA SHARP: Instead
of just showing
a basic card that shows
Larry doing the activity, now
with Canvas, we can build
in something much more
interactive.
For example, we could
put in dynamic elements
on the display.
In this case, it allows us to
show an energy bar for Larry.
MANDY CHAN: So, in addition to
show the energy and happiness
level of your pet by
using the energy bar,
we also want to
show the user how
they can progress in the game
by collecting different badges.
With Rich Responses, I had a
difficult decision to make.
Should I show Larry the
hamster eating the broccoli?
Or should I show the badge?
So, before Interactive
Canvas was available,
I actually used the screen
to show that Larry's
eating the broccoli.
And I used the
spoken prompt to tell
the user they earned a badge.
DARLA SHARP: I think that was,
when using Rich Responses,
a pretty smart way to
balance the modalities.
But now that we have
Canvas, where we can now
show multiple images
on the same screen,
and some of them even
being dynamic, like a GIF
here, now you can
see not only how
Larry is feeling
with the energy bar,
but you can also see how you're
progressing through the game
by earning badges.
MANDY CHAN: So
the lesson learned
here is with Interactive
Canvas, objects on the screen
can come to life
with a single touch.
They can react by fading,
animating, or even talking
to you.
DARLA SHARP: So
now we've covered
how to build for voice only
and also for multimodal.
Of the three products we
spoke about at the beginning
of the talk that we were
going to build our action for,
the one that we haven't
talked about is mobile.
So what do we need to do, based
on what we've done so far,
to get our action
to work on mobile?
The good news is
absolutely nothing.
By using the strategy of
building from voice to Rich
Responses and augmenting
with Canvas if it applies
to your category,
then you don't have
to do anything extra for
mobile to work specifically.
This is a big win for you.
By doing this solid approach,
you can scale to many devices
without a lot of heavy
lifting on your part.
MANDY CHAN: So there
are some use cases
that the phone is preferred
over other devices.
The above three use cases,
transaction, notification,
account linking,
are good examples.
They all have a
common theme, which
is the physical control
over the device.
Mobile is a massive market
that you don't want to miss.
It is a great way for you to
engage with the user on the go
or in a more private manner.
So there are different
scenarios that
requires users to
transfer from one device
to another for
different reasons.
One reason is you need
to do account linking.
So that requires the
users to use their phone
for security reasons.
The second reason could be
you need to show a image.
But what if your user
trigger your action
from a home speaker?
So what we can do is we check
if the user has any devices that
can support screen output.
If the user does has a device
that support screen output,
we simply continue the
conversation over there.
Let's see how we
do that in code.
So first, we check if the
user have any devices that
can support screen output.
And we saw that in a constant
called screenAvailable,
we then defined three
constant contexts.
Context is the
reason why we need
to transfer the user from
one device to another.
Notification is the
message that will
be displayed on the screen
on the target device.
Capabilities is an
array of capabilities
that your target
device must support.
In this case, all we care is
the device should have a screen.
So if the current device that's
being used, we have a screen,
we can show the image,
carousel, basic card, easily.
And if the current
device that's being used,
that doesn't
support screen, this
is where we check the
constant screenAvailable.
Does the user have
any other device
that can support screen output?
If yes, we created
a new instance
called NewService that parsing
the three constants that we
define earlier.
Finally, if-- we need
to go to the next page.
Finally, if the user
doesn't have any device that
can support screen output,
we simply say, sorry,
you need a screen
to see the pictures.
DARLA SHARP: So we managed to
cover how to take one action,
focus on the capabilities,
create a solid voice experience
that scales.
As you try this
yourselves, here's
a few tools to keep in mind
that can be really helpful.
It's easy to get
lost in your code
when you're trying to figure
out how to balance these two
modalities.
I highly recommend stepping
away from the computer,
using a pen and paper,
and figuring out
how you want these dialogues to
flow with the voice and screen
back to back.
This is really simple, and you
do not need very much skill
to do this.
A simple drawing with a pen, a
paper, and some stick figures
goes a long way.
MANDY CHAN: UI toolkit
includes some image templates
that can allow you to
create a wireframe.
It shows you how Rich Responses
can look in different devices.
In this example,
we have basic card.
You can really see how
it looks on a mobile
versus a smart displays.
Another tool that I
want to talk about
is the Action Simulator, where
you can find in the Actions
on Google console.
So this is where you
probably spend a lot of time
testing your Actions.
A couple things I
want to touch on
is, the first is you can really
toggle between those devices
to see how your
action look like.
And you can also check how your
Canvas, Interactive Canvas,
look like in the Simulator.
Second thing I want to talk
about is the Audio Tech.
This is where you can play--
can we click?
Yeah, this is the Audio Tech,
in case anyone couldn't find it.
This is where you can
play with the SSML tech,
add pauses, change volume,
pitch of your voice,
and even add the ambient
sound in the background
while the speaking
prompt is running.
So, OK, we have done it.
We have covered a lot today.
To sum up, we just want to
run through the quick summary
of what we have learned
from building this game.
We talk about using
SSML in conjunction
with the Sound Library
that can help you
create layers for your Action.
Be sure to have several branches
in your dialogue to create
a solid voice first experience.
DARLA SHARP: Then
use dialogue to guide
the user using questions
instead of statements.
If your Action uses
a screen, there
are a lot of tools in
your Rich Response toolbox
to augment the voice experience.
MANDY CHAN: Interactive
Canvas is a great new feature
to create gaming experience
using technology you already
know, HTML, CSS, and JavaScript.
If you are a game developer,
make sure you check it out.
It is in Developer
Preview, which
means you can start
building games today.
You just cannot deploy
it to the production yet.
DARLA SHARP: And finally, if you
build one custom Action using
the techniques we
described today,
you get a single experience
that scales across devices.
We covered a lot today about
how conversation design applies
to our action.
But there's lots more to learn.
I highly recommend visiting
the actions.google.com/design
website to learn more
about conversation design.
And there's also been lots of
good talks from years prior.
There's also a talk tomorrow
at 2:30 by Cathy Pearl
and Jessica
Earley-Cha on Stage 8,
where you can learn more about
designing quality conversations
for the Google Assistant.
And to learn more about how
to use Interactive Canvas
and how to implement
it in the code,
there was a talk earlier today
that you can check out tomorrow
on YouTube.
MANDY CHAN: So here
are all the resources
that we have covered
today, how to leverage
the voice and visual component
that our platform provides,
in addition to that,
samples and tools that can
help you get started quickly.
Thank you so much for coming.
Please let us know how
you do like this talk.
I hope you enjoyed
this talk, and share
the feedback in the I/O app.
So this game is still
work in progress.
So that means that
we will open source
this game after I/O.
Follow me on Twitter
@MandyChanNYC to get
the latest update
about the game and Larry.
DARLA SHARP: OK.
MANDY CHAN: Have fun--
DARLA SHARP: That's it.
MANDY CHAN: --building
your Actions.
DARLA SHARP: Thanks for coming.
[GOOGLE LOGO MUSIC]